okay so today we're going to look at
some more hr indoctrination videos many
of you are personally familiar with this
kind of thing you perhaps had to endure
them yourself um i don't have to endure
them but i choose to for your sake
i do this in order to suffer alongside
you this is how compassionate i am
and also i do it for youtube views so
it's ki it's a win-win it's sort of like
it's 50 50
both of them anyway this is this one's
from a company called ej4
which puts these kinds of videos
together and they distribute them to
all sorts of other companies that they
do in their hr
training session slash brainwashing
sessions and they've worked with such
notable corporations as
pepsi medieval times krispy kreme
and plenty of others so without further
ado let's
let's take a look
[Music]
maybe you've seen this graphic floating
around the internet
it was designed by andrew m ibrahim and
he gives ibram x kendi
and other modern anti-racism writers
credit for many of the ideas within the
graphic
i want to give you a quick overview of
it because it's a useful tool
and then i want to show you a similar
graphic we made that focuses on an
anti-racism continuum for the workplace
so let's get into dr ibrahim's graphic
real quick
this graphic is broken down into three
phases
as a person on a journey towards
becoming anti-racist you fall somewhere
within this continuum
ibrahim breaks this continuum into three
main groups
the fear zone the learning zone
and the growth zone okay so what does
any of this have to do with donuts
racist donut i mean why should an
employee at krispy kreme
for example need to know any of this i
mean i say no
as if this is real information as if
there's anything as if this is anything
other than contrived cultish nonsense
but
uh maybe no isn't the right word but the
point is you're you're
you're an employee at krispy kreme back
at it again at krispy kreme
you make donuts for living you don't
even make them actually you just watch
them on a conveyor belt
then they come out and they're delicious
for the first 60 seconds that they come
out and then they're inedible thereafter
and that's your job why do you need to
be anti-racist
to do that job maybe we'll find out
let's uh let's keep watching
you can see that in the fear zone we're
either denying that racism is a problem
or we're not interested in or willing to
take action to combat it
that is a comfortable space for people
with race privilege
okay um so i guess i'm in the fear zone
i i guess i am it's weird because i
don't feel afraid but
no be afraid yeah i do deny that
anti-black racism is a big problem in
society i deny that it's i deny that i
deny that it's a big problem i think
it's it's one of the
of the lesser significant problems
actually
i think there's very little of it in
reality in this country anyway in modern
times
and all of our con and all of our
cultural institutions are dedicated to
elevating racial minorities often at the
expense of white people so yes
um i deny the pres the premise
as far as not being interested yeah
again i'm i'm not really interested in
what
this woman has to say like i don't care
i don't care
i don't care what any race cultist or
critical race theorist thinks
deny don't care that's me
but rather than engaging with those
viewpoints of course the strategy here
is always to label them
it's never to engage it never is it's
always the strategy is always simply to
label we're going to slap a label on
that
and put it in a box in this case we're
just going to call that fear let's uh
let's continue
people sometimes get offended by that
term race privilege
so let me quickly define it to ease any
defensive feelings toward that
someone's ability to be in the fear zone
means that their life is not
negatively impacted by the color of
their skin it's not saying that their
life is easy
that they've not had to work hard and it
doesn't negate struggles
it simply means that their life is not
negatively impacted by the color of
their skin
that's race privilege and it's important
to know not everyone has that luxury
not everyone has that luxury i mean
that's that's true um
so what what people don't have
that luxury let's let's think about that
affirmative action
is actual real-life systemic
discrimination explicitly set against
white people that's that's what it is
also as a white person you're constantly
berated as racist and forced to endure
stuff like this
you're cast as society's villains so
yeah your life can be negatively
impacted by the color of your skin
as a white person so who has the race
privilege exactly
if you're ready to move out of the fear
zone then you start to do some of these
things
in the learning zone asking questions
reading books
evaluating your privilege listening to
people who look different than you
and guess what some of the things in
this learning zone are going to be
shocking and upsetting and uncomfortable
because you'll learn that things you
hoped weren't true
in fact are true the learning zone
we're in the learning zone i'm learning
uh you know
i i just like i love the condescending
nature to it like we're we're in a
kindergarten class now
these are all these are adults at a you
know probably
they're they're working for a living at
a company and
being condescended to in this way okay
kids we're in the learning zone now
let me put you in the learning zone lady
want to learn something
shocking here um you're full of
that might be a surprising factoid for
you i know
and by the way i'm i'm still waiting
until this circles back around to donuts
or to anything
that would be helpful or necessary for
someone working at pepsi or krispy kreme
or medieval times
thanks to you fair winch one of these
companies to actually
know in order to do their job but things
are going to get things get
so we've started annoying and irritating
and now things are going to take a
darker turn and get and get and get
pretty um pretty disturbing let's let's
keep going
now when you start to learn about and
get shocked by the experiences of others
then hopefully you become motivated to
push yourself into the growth zone
you start to speak out you promote and
advocate for policies that are
anti-racist
and you yield your power to marginalized
groups there
you see how she sneaks that in there you
she just sneaks it right in
yield your power to marginalized groups
hey nothing to worry about you know it's
no big deal just give up your status and
position that you've achieved
through hard work and effort and hand it
over to some other random person based
purely on
the color of their skin no big deal
don't freak out about it we're just
telling you to be a whimpering
submissive
constantly apologizing and flagellating
yourself and
and gratefully accept your own
mistreatment that's all
yield your power they don't they don't
say
submit surrender anything it's
yield your power
let's continue the important thing to
know here is that in order to move
through this journey
to transition from the fear zone to the
learning zone to the growth zone
you have to put in work you have to
allow for mental shifts
and you have to allow yourself to be
uncomfortable
put in work there it is everyone take a
drink
in this case my drink of choice will be
uh gasoline just to put myself
out of my misery or maybe not because i
think i get the feeling that's exactly
what this lady would want me to do
as a white man as the dreaded white man
the white man
we're gonna skip ahead a little bit um
this this video this goes on
forever we're gonna go a little bit
further ahead and
see what else we can find within this
zone
you're complacent working in an
organization that excludes people of
marginalized groups
you're complacent working in an
organization that demonstrates inequity
in pay hiring and leadership you
intentionally or
unintentionally choose to work most
closely with people who look like you
you either do not understand or do not
believe in the value that diversity
brings to an organization
or you make comments or jokes that
oppress marginalized groups
this list can continue but you get the
idea
where to begin first she says
that you're in the fear zone if you're
complacent
while working in a company that excludes
people of color
no ma'am if i may assume you're gender
it's not
complacency it's just that well what's
the problem
nobody works in a company like that
because no such company
exists anywhere in the country which is
a good thing
should celebrate that there is no
company
anywhere in the country that excludes
people
based on the color of their skin unless
we're talking about affirmative action
and they're uh singling out white people
and asians
so there are there are no companies
excluding racial minorities
except for asians which is which is an
affirmative action policy that the left
endorses other than that it's not
happening it doesn't exist
so i am complacent in the face of a
non-existent problem
yeah i'm complacent in the face of all
non-existent problems i'm very
complacent about them
because they're not they're they're just
they're not real it's a made-up tale
also she uses the phrase um
or she says you're in the fear zone if
you don't value if you don't believe in
the value of diversity
once again you see not going to bother
explaining
why diversity matters in and of itself
not going to bother explaining it just
if you don't agree with her it's because
you're afraid
i don't believe in the value of
diversity in and of itself
don't see how a company is made better
simply through diverse diversity
i can see how companies are made better
by hiring people who are very good at
doing the job and if diversity is a
byproduct of that then fantastic
and then uh she uses the phrase comments
or
jokes that oppress
marginalized groups what is you know
what i'm gonna
uh what is the definition just just for
fun the dictionary definition of the
word oppressed because it comes up so
often
and you can only do this it's like they
they've started changing the dictionary
definitions of things to more align with
critical race theory but
as of right now the dictionary
definition of oppress
is to keep someone in subservience and
hardship
especially by the unjust exercise of
authority
so through a joke
you are exercising authority that keeps
someone in subservience
through a joke that's the joke right
okay let's keep going what are some
characteristics that you can work
towards that indicate you're moving from
the fear zone to the learning zone
yeah i don't care shut up um we don't
need your homework assignments
let's skip what we're going to do is
we're going to skip all the way to
because like i said this goes on
and my god if you work for one of these
companies you probably have to endure
it's like this is a this is a 10 or 20
minute video 15 minute video something
um and you you probably have to endure a
whole battery of these a whole series of
these i can't even imagine it
but let's skip to the end and see how
all of this
wraps up don't assume that you can speak
for a minority group
not all people of color have the same
experience and the same needs
likewise not all black people have the
same experiences or needs
going further not all black women have
the same experiences and needs
and guess what not all black women
living in the midwest between the ages
of 40 and 45 with bachelor's degrees
have the same experiences or
needs while it might be appropriate for
you to speak for a specific person of
color in your organization
maybe you're promoting their work or
defending them it's
never appropriate for you to speak for
an entire group of people especially one
that you're not part of
yeah uh okay yes
i know that well just so you know not
all black people have the same
experiences
obviously who are you talking to
who is this what what straw man have you
just
constructed some people without brains
do an awful lot of talking
my lord first of all as was obvious from
the start
um but especially obvious now and we got
in from that segment there
this is a brainwashing video
specifically directed towards
white employees they don't even pretend
anymore that this is for everybody
it's very clear there this is for white
people we are talking to you
whitey white devil and just so you know
okay that is illegal this is illegal you
know
i'm not a lawyer i don't have to be i
know
that you cannot single out employees
based on race and subject them to
different treatment based on their race
you can't do that it is extremely
illegal
second she says and this is this is
great it's just a perfect place to end
it because she says
after this whole video she says you
can't lump all people of one race
together and speak for them
that's exactly what she's doing for the
whole video
she is lumping all white people together
and making a whole series of assumptions
insulting demeaning degrading
assumptions
about them and speaking both
to them in a demeaning way which is
problem number one and also speaking for
them
because she is saying as a non-white
person herself she said
saying well this is what you white
people need to do
i i know what you need i'll tell you
what you need
doing exactly what she is accusing
others of doing
and that is the whole basis of critical
race theory it is demeaning
insulting horrifying but it's not going
to go anywhere
until we start fighting this stuff in
court
that's the only way it stops